okay number one solve three to the 2x
power equals 81 so what you want to do
on this problem is this is called the a
one-to-one property of exponents you
want to try to get these bases to be the
same so I recognize that 81 is 3 to the
4th power and here we have 3 to the 2x
power now that the bases are the same we
can just set the exponents equal to x
equals 4 divide both sides by 2 and x
equals 2 and you got it if you want to
jump to a particular part of this review
there's time stamps in the description
below you can go down there and see what
topics were going to cover and jump to
those sections but for number 2 it says
rewrite log base 2 of 1/8 equal to
negative 3 in exponential form so what
we're doing is we're rewriting it and an
easy way to do this is to think about
logs and exponential functions as
inverses which they are and what you can
do is if you have a log base 2 you can
exponentiate both sides using base 2 so
you're raising both sides using that
common base 2 here and so what you're
going to do now is these are inverses
they cancel or undo one another and you
just have two to the negative third
power equals 1/8 and you've rewritten it
so for number 3 this is the reverse of
number 2 it says rewrite 5 to the
negative 4 power equals 1 over 625 in
the logarithmic form so same idea we've
got 5 to the negative 4 equals 1 over
625
but because we're exponentiating we have
5 raised to an exponent what we're going
to do is we're going to do the inverse
we're going to take the log base 5 of
both sides of the equation to keep it
balanced right and these are inverses
they undo one another or cancel each
other out and now you've rewritten it in
the logarithmic form if you want to go
back to the exponential form you would
just exponentiate or raise both sides
using base five and you got it so for
number four it says evaluate which just
means find the value of log base five of
square root of five now there's a little
bit of a trick I guess you could say to
this problem in the sense that you have
to remember that square roots are really
like the one-half power if it was the
cube root this would be like the
one-third power so that denominator is
the root but now what we have is we have
log base five
exponential function with base five
those are inverses and you just get one
half okay so for number five it says
find the x-intercept of this function
three natural log of x plus two so when
you're finding the x-intercept you're
finding out where it crosses the x-axis
but that's where the y coordinate is
equal to zero now when we see f of X we
think of our output or our y-value and
we're setting that equal to zero so now
all we have to do is solve for x and
when you look at natural log or think of
natural log remember this is really like
log base E they don't write the base e
there but you can put it in there just
to help remind you let's go ahead and
divide both sides by three okay so now
we have zero equals natural log which
remember is base e of x plus two and now
what we're going to do is just like
we've been doing we're going to do the
inverse of natural log which is to
exponentiate or raise both sides using
the natural base e these are inverses
they undo one another cancel each other
out e to the 0 equals 1 and all we have
to do is subtract 2 from both sides and
you can see that x equals negative 1 now
one thing you want to be careful of when
you're working with log equations is
that you don't get an extraneous
solution or an extraneous root so you'd
want to go ahead and put that back in
make sure that this quantity is always
going to be positive you don't want to
be 0 or negative that's not a d
restricted domain for logs or natural
logs so for number six it says solve log
of 4 minus X equals log of 100 so this
is very similar to the first question
that we did using the exponents but here
what we have is if they don't write the
base these are understood to be called
common logs log base 10 and this is
called the one-to-one property of logs
so what we can do is just set the
arguments equal to one another 4 minus x
equals 100 and then just solve so I'm
going to subtract 4 from both sides
multiply both sides by negative 1 or
divide both sides by negative 1 and x
equals negative 96 now again you want to
put it back in just make sure that the
you're not taking the log of a 0 or a
negative number okay for number seven it
says evaluate which remember just means
find the value of the log base 7 of the
fourth root of 49 this question is very
similar to this question so what do you
think how would you do this one well
forty-nine I know
two for three it is really like the one
fourth power but 49 is actually seven
squared okay so I'm just replacing it
with seven squared to the one fourth
power power to power we multiply so we
have log base 7 of 7 to the two force
which is one-half these are inverses ok
log base seven an exponential function
with base seven and so we just end up
getting one-half for number eight we're
working with condensing and number nine
were working with expanding log so this
is using the properties of logs if you
have questions about any of these
problems on this review I've got videos
on all these topics on my mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel so you can
check those out if you get stuck with
any of these but the first step here is
you can see what I'm doing is I'm
bringing up that coefficient as a power
that's called the power property so it
comes up from in front of the log to an
exponent but when you add what do you do
to the arguments you multiply them and
when you subtract what you do to the
arguments you divide now one thing you
want to be careful of is you're not
dividing the log by Z to the fourth just
the arguments by Z to the fourth so
that's a kind of mistake students
sometimes make okay now for number nine
what we're doing is we're expanding so
we're kind of doing this in Reverse
right so you can see we've got log base
three of X to the fifth power now we're
dividing remember when you divide you
subtract so minus log base three of
square root of Y which I'm just going to
write as y to the one-half power times Z
now remember when you multiply it what
do you do you write it as a sum of logs
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
put this in parentheses minus log base 3
of Y to the one half plus because
remember we're multiplying so we add log
base 3 of Z okay so now what what I'm
going to do is I'm going to distribute
this negative into the parentheses okay
so we have log base 3 of X minus log
flips log base 3 of Y to the one half
which by the way we can bring that one
half down in front and then we have
distributing the negative we get minus
log base 3 of Z and you've got it just
bring down that one half in front now
sometimes what students get a little bit
confused with is
that when you have more than one
quantity in the denominator so more than
one client that you're dividing by
everything that's in the denominator
those log you're going to be subtracting
all the arguments that are in the
numerator those logs you're gonna be
adding are they're gonna be positive
logs so that's just a quick way to see
if you're on the right track with
expanding logarithms okay number 10 and
it says what quadrant is the angle theta
equals 29 PI over 15 in so one thing I
like to do with these improper fractions
like this I see how many times is 15 go
into 29 well it goes into 29 once with
14 left over so this is really like 1 in
14 15 hi so now when you go to your
circle here you can see that 1 pi is
like 180 degrees it's a half revolution
right and then another 14 15 so that's
not quite one whole pie so it doesn't
quite reach all the way to 2 pi it's
gonna be somewhere right about there
okay and so you can see that's going to
put us in the one two three fourth
quadrant so we could say quadrant 4
Roman numeral four or the number four
okay for number 11 it says find one
positive and one negative coterminal
angle with three PI over seven so when
we think of the word ko that means same
terminal means where it terminates so
it's gonna be in the same position on
that circle with 3 PI over 7 so what you
can do is you can take 3 PI over 7 and
add 2 pi so when you add 2 pi that's
like going once around you know 1
revolution 360 degrees so you'd end up
in the same spot or you could do 3 PI
over 7 minus 2 pi so minus 2 pi just
means that you're going the opposite
direction right so positive or going
counterclockwise negative you're going
clockwise but in either case you're
going one revolution you're ending up in
the same spot but the key here is really
to get common denominators so I'm going
to multiply the numerator and
denominator here by 7 over 7 so that
gives us 14 PI over 7 plus 3 PI over 7
is 17 PI over seven and over here we
have 3 PI minus 14 PI which is a
negative 11 PI over 7 so one positive
one negative now sometimes when you're
doing these problems you might have to
add 2 pi multiple times to get to a
positive angle or subtract 2 pi
multiple times to get to a negative
angle so for number 12 it says finding
the complement and the supplement of
five PI over seven so when we talk about
complement we're talking about the angle
that adds up to 90 degrees with this
angle or in radians that's going to be
PI over two and we talked about
supplement we're talking about the angle
it adds up to 180 degrees
but in radians we're talking about the
angles add up to PI radians so what we
can do to find the complement is we just
take PI over two minus five PI over
seven so it's like taking 90 degrees
minus the angle but here what we want to
do is we want to get a common
denominator so I'm gonna multiply this
by seven over seven this by two over two
this gives us seven PI over fourteen
minus ten PI over fourteen let's write
that down seven PI over fourteen minus
ten PI over fourteen but you see how
this is giving us a negative 3 PI over
14 if you get a negative angle that just
tells you that there's no complement so
in this case we're just gonna say no
complement all right but for the
supplement that's going to be PI over
180 degrees minus the angle so 180 minus
five PI over seven or PI minus five PI
over seven we want to get a common
denominator so I'm gonna multiply top
and bottom by seven so I get 7 PI over
seven minus five PI over seven which is
two PI over seven and you can see that
there is a supplement two PI over seven
if it came out negative then we would
just say there's no supplement so that's
an important question to go over now
number 13 it says rewrite the angle in
degrees so how do we convert from
radians to degrees well you want to
remember this conversion factor 180 over
PI so 180 degrees is the same as PI
radians and you can see I've set this up
in such a way that the ratings in the
numerator cancel with the PI radians in
the denominator and so we're just left
with 360 over 15 or what you can do is
do a little bit of cross reducing 15
goes in here once 15 goes in here 12
times 2 times 24 2 times 12 is 24
degrees right okay so for number 14 it
says find the arc length and the area of
a sector of a circle with radius 4
centimeters and central angle 30 degrees
so we're trying to find that our Klenk
right there and then the area of that
pie slice right so there's two formulas
you want to add your notes sheet s
equals R theta
and area equals 1/2 R squared theta but
to use these two formulas that central
angle has to be in radians not degrees
so just like we were doing over here we
can convert the radians to degrees by
multiplying by PI over 180 right so the
degrees cancel with the degrees and we
have 30 PI over 180 which reduces to PI
over 6 and you probably already know
this from your unit circles so when you
were studying unit circle so the arc
length s is equal to 4 times the central
angle which we said was PI over 6 so we
get 4 PI over 6 which is 2 PI over 3
centimeters because our Klank is just
distance just one-dimensional right but
for the area of the inside we're gonna
do 1/2 the radius squared so 4 squared
times that central angle again you want
to make sure that's in radians and all
we have to do is just simplify so we
have 4 squared is 16 which is like 16
over 1 times 1/2 times pi over 6 we can
do a little bit reducing 2 goes in here
once 2 goes in your 8 2 goes in here 3
times 2 goes in here 4 times if we
multiply all the numerators together and
all the denominators together you can
see we're getting 4 PI over 3
centimeters squared since its area okay
number 15 it says a 10-inch diameter
wheel is rotating at 40 revolutions per
minute so let's just draw a picture so
there's a 10-inch diameter a wheel it's
rotating at 40 revolutions per per means
divided by okay for one minute but we
want to find the angular speed in
radians per minute and also the linear
speed and feet per minute so let's start
with angular speed so really what this
problem is is like a unit conversion
problem so we have 40 revolutions per
one minute but for every one revolution
meaning once this wheel turns you know
one revolution that's the same as 2 pi
radians remember 2pi is the same as 360
degrees so notice the revolutions in the
nanami are and the revolutions in the
numerator they cancel and we're left
with radians per minute meaning radians
divided by minutes so if we multiply the
numerators together we get 80 PI radians
per one times one is just one minute
so 80 PI radians per minute
now linear speed I'm going to do the
same thing just think about this as a
unit conversion problem 40 revolutions
per 1 minute but now what I'm going to
do is for every one revolution every
time this turns once around this wheel
how far is it traveling well it's
traveling one circumference right that
distance that perimeter is one
circumference and we know the
circumference is pi times diameter so
that's 10 pi so now you can see that's
in inches so the revolutions cancel we
have inches per minute but we want feet
per minute so now we're just gonna say
12 inches for every one foot and the
inches cancel numerator and denominator
so you are on the right track as long as
the units are canceling numerator and
denominator and these are equivalent one
foot is equal to 12 inches we're not
changing the value of this expression
here we're just changing the unit so now
we've got what we want which is feet per
minute let's multiply all the numerators
all the denominators and we'll divide so
let's see that's 40 times 10 times 1
that's 400 PI 400 PI and 1 times 1 times
12 is 12 so we have 400 PI over 12 feet
per sorry that was feet per minute yes
feet per minute and you can reduce this
down further you know to lowest terms
for number 16 it says find the XY point
on the unit circle that corresponds to 7
PI over 6 so again you really want to
know your unit circle 7 PI over 6 is
really the same thing as 6 goes into 7
once with one left over it's like 1 in
160 I so you're going PI which is like
180 degrees plus one-sixth of Pi so like
1/6 which is right there
now 1/6 of pi is the same as PI over 6
right so what that means is that you
know this point right here on the unit
circle is going to be the same
coordinates as the PI over 6 in the
first quadrant the only difference is
that in the third quadrant here the x
coordinate and the y coordinate are both
negative so if you remember your
30-degree or your PI over 6 in the first
quadrant that's root 3 over 2 comma 1/2
it's in the third quadrant now so it's
going to be negative square root 3 over
2 comma negative 1/2 if you want to see
more about the unit circle I've got a
video of my resume
- during a YouTube channel called master
the unit circle so check that one out
okay number 17 and says find the exact
value of secant of theta given this
triangle here so remember secant and
cosine are reciprocals of one another so
what we need to do is we need to find
the cosine which is the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse and you can remember
your acronym so Toa right and cosine is
that adjacent over hypotenuse so Jason
is next to or the hypotenuse one thing
is that we're gonna take the reciprocal
which really means that it's gonna be
the hypotenuse over the adjacent we have
to do the Pythagorean theorem if you do
that five squared plus twelve squared
equals C squared
you'll find that C equals thirteen this
is one of the common Pythagorean triples
a good one to memorize so hypotenuse
over adjacent is just going to be secant
of theta equals 13/12
and you got it for number 18 evaluate
the cosecant of 45 degrees now again if
you know your unit circle over here at
45 degrees we know that the coordinates
are root 2 over 2 comma root 2 over 2
but the cosecant is really the
reciprocal of the sine and on the unit
circle the sine is the Y value so if we
take the reciprocal that's going to be 2
over square root of 2 if we multiply by
square root of 2 over square root of 2
to rationalize square root of 2 times
square root of 2 is square root of 4
which is 2 the numerator 2 times square
root of 2 these cancel and so we're just
left with square root of 2 so for number
19 given that the tangent of theta
equals 4 and the cosecant of theta
equals square root of 17 over 4 how
would you find the cosine of 90 minus
theta so on a problem like this is good
to draw a triangle okay so here's your
angle theta the tangent of theta is 4
which is like 4 over 1 remember tangent
is opposite / adjacent so it's opposite
side over the adjacent side 1 and the
cosecant which is the hypotenuse over
opposite so that's going to be square
root of 17 over opposite which is 4 now
we have our triangle we want to find the
cosine of 90 minus theta and now you can
either memorize that cosine of 90 minus
theta is the same as sine of theta these
are called Co functions or if you see
that this angle is Theta this angle here
has
90 minus theta because these two angles
have to add up to 90 plus this 90
cuihuan 80 for the triangle sum cosine
if you position yourself at the 90 minus
theta angle is the adjacent side 4 over
the hypotenuse which is square root of
17 now we just have to rationalize and
you can see we're getting 4 squared of
17 over 17 and you got it
okay for number 20 if cosine of theta is
1/2 find the value of theta where theta
is in between 0 and 90s we're basically
telling us that in the first quadrant
okay 0 to 90 where is the cosine of 1/2
well remember cosine on the unit circle
is the x-coordinate and we're saying
where is the x-coordinate 1/2 and that's
going to be right here at the point 1/2
comma square root 3 over 2 and if you
know you're in your unit circle this is
a 60-degree angle so this is going to be
60 degrees now if they said between 0
and PI over 2 I would have put the
answer in radians PI over 3 but here
it's from 0 to 90 degrees so 421 it says
find the value of x so we're doing a
little bit of trigonometry here what
trig function ties together this angle
this side and this side well you can see
its opposite and adjacent so we're back
to tangent again Toa
that's a tangent of 31 degrees equals
the opposite side over the adjacent side
and now if we just multiply both sides
by 9 you can see that x equals 9 times
the tangent of 31 you can do that on
your calculator or leave it as an exact
answer there for number 22 it says given
the figure below determine the cosine of
theta now notice they give us this point
here negative 18 negative 15 so we're
going on the left 8 8 so negative 8 and
we're going down 15 negative 15 if you
do the Pythagorean theorem you're gonna
find out that this hypotenuse is 17 now
the hypotenuse so the radius is always
going to be positive but you know the x
coordinate y coordinate can be negative
so left negative right positive down
negative positive but remember when you
do the cosine what we're looking at is
the adjacent side over the hypotenuse so
you position yourself at the central
angle here and you say okay adjacent
next to over hypotenuse which is across
from the right angle 17 and you got it
so the key here was really to
do the Pythagorean theorem or know your
Pythagorean triples to find that
hypotenuse and then know your ratios
cosine is adjacent divided by hypotenuse
okay for number 23 state the quadrant in
which the angle theta lies if the
cosecant is greater than zero meaning
positive and the tangent of theta is
less than zero meaning negative so let's
draw a picture here so remember in the
first quadrant both the X and the y are
positive in the second quadrant the X is
negative the Y is positive and the third
quadrants are both negative and the
fourth quadrant X is positive Y is
negative remember on our unit circle we
know that the sine is going to be
positive when the y coordinate is
positive and since cosecant is the
reciprocal of sine wherever the sine is
positive the cosecant is also going to
be positive so that means it could be in
the first quadrant or the second
quadrant but tangent remember on the
unit circle is the y-coordinate divided
by the x coordinate right so in order
for it to be less than zero getting
negative either the Y is positive and X
is negative or vice versa so in this
case you can see that tangent would be
negative here in the second quadrant or
here in the fourth quadrant but you see
how they overlap it here in the second
quadrant so that means that theta must
be in quadrant number two or you can
write it with a Roman numeral two so now
for 24 it says solve the cosecant of
theta equals negative two where theta is
in between 0 and 2pi ok so again we're
going to the unit circle you can see a
lot of unit circle here in the second
quarter this is saying cosecant of what
angle it goes negative two now remember
cosecant is really like 1 over sine of
theta right if we take the reciprocal of
both sides here you can see that sine of
theta would equal negative 1/2 so
wherever cosecant equals negative 2 is
the same place that sine is equal to
negative 1/2 remember sine is the y
coordinate on the unit circle and we're
saying well where is sine or the Y value
I should say negative 1/2 well that's
going to be right here okay at a 30
degree reference angle but here they
want the answer in radians so this is a
PI over 6 degree reference angle this is
PI plus PI over 6 which is 7 PI over 6
or you could say 2 pi minus PI over 6
which is 11 PI over 6
so review your unit circle if you need
to but again remember sine is the Y
value for 25 sketch the graph of f of X
equals two sine one-half of X plus PI
over two plus one okay the first thing I
would do on this one is think of f of X
is like Y here I'm going to factor out
this coefficient in front of the X so
this is going to be 2 sine one-half X
plus PI now if you notice if you
distribute the 1/2 you're going to get
1/2 X plus PI over 2 back and so now
what we want to do is want to figure out
what this scale is we want to find out
what the period is and what you do is
use this formula here period equals two
pi divided by B 1/2 is our B value so 2
pi divided by 1/2 when you divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so this actually comes out to
4 pi so I'm just going to divide this by
in four pieces so I'm going to think of
this as 1 PI 2 pi 3 PI 4 PI ok and then
now what I'm going to do is take a look
at the transformation so the 2 is going
to be like a vertical stretch by to the
plus PI is actually gonna have the
opposite effect it's going to shift the
graph left pi and this one is gonna
shift the graph up 1 so we can think of
this as left pi up 1 this is gonna go
left pi up 1 so we can think of that
kind of like as our new origin okay like
kind of like our new starting point so
now we're just going to graph this
function right here from from this new
starting point so sine graph starts at
the midline okay and then it goes up to
the maximum back to the midline down to
the minimum and then back to the midline
and then it repeats so the graph looks
something like that
so what I'm doing is I'm using this form
here a sine be X minus h plus K a is
like the amplitude or the vertical
stretch D is related to the period by
this form of 2 PI over B and the h and
the K are the shifts the shifting left
and right up and down remember the one
group of the X has the opposite effect
you want to see more of these ones I
have graphing sine cosine tangent on my
Marv's math tutor YouTube channel you
can check out those ok number 26 it says
evaluate the arc cosine
negative square root 3 over 2 so when we
evaluate the arc cosine this is the same
as the cosine inverse and the important
thing to remember is that when you're
finding the cosine inverse you want to
restrict yourself from 0 to PI so you're
going to be in the first quadrant or the
second quadrant if you're finding arc
sine or arc tangent excuse me you're
going to be between negative PI over two
and positive PI over two so that's the
restricted domain for the our cosine or
the arc sine or the arc tangent so we're
asking ourselves cosine of what angle
equals negative square root 3 over 2 and
we know that that occurs right here at 5
PI over 6 and again this is going back
to the unit circle finding the x
coordinate on the unit circle between 0
and pi where the x coordinate is
negative root 3 over 2 so this point
right here at 5 PI over 6 is negative
root 3 over 2 comma 1/2 okay number 27
it says use an inverse function to write
theta as a function of X okay so what
does that mean when they say write theta
as a function of X well what they mean
is they want us to get the theta by
itself on one side of the equation and
then everything else on the other side
right so let's think of a trig function
that relates this angle this side and
this side well you can see it's the
opposite and the adjacent so that's
going to be tangent so tangent of theta
equals 4 over X but we want to get theta
by itself so let's go ahead and take the
tangent inverse of both sides so the
tangent inverse of the left tangent
inverse of the right and you can see
those are undoing one another so we have
theta equals tangent inverse of 4 over X
and you've got it okay so now let's go
ahead and look at number 28 that says
evaluate the arc tangent of tangent of
3pi over 4 so we can do is we're going
to start from the inside and work our
way out so when we look at tangent of 3
PI over 4 that's going to be right here
and that's the point on your unit circle
where the coordinates are root 2 over 2
negative and positive root 2 over 2 so
if we find the tangent of 3 PI over 4
that's going to be the y-coordinate
divided by the x-coordinate anything
divided by itself is 1 but a positive
divided by a negative is going to be a
negative 1 so what we have so far now is
arc tangent which I'm just
right as tangent inverse this quantity
came out to negative one and so now
we're saying tangent of what angle
equals negative one but keep in mind
just like we were talking about up here
when you're finding the tangent inverse
you're restricted from negative PI over
2 to positive PI over 2 that's the
restricted domain so tans and what angle
equals negative one that's actually
going to be right here at negative PI
over 4 now some students will mistakenly
you know go all the way around and say
oh that's you know 7 PI over 4 but you
want to just restrict yourself from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
if you end up in the fourth quadrant
just make it a negative angle and you
got it the other mistake that students
sometimes make is they say well Mario
isn't the tangent and our tangent aren't
those inverses shouldn't this just be 3
PI over 4 well that's only true if this
angle was in that restricted domain from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
otherwise it's good to start from the
inside you know solve that work your way
out ok number 29 it says write an
algebraic expression that's equivalent
to the sine of tangent inverse of 2x
okay so this a little bit more
challenging problem again we like to
start from the inside work our way out
tangent inverse of 2x is really saying
tangent of what angle equals 2x because
you can see if you take the tangent
inverse of both sides theta would be the
tangent inverse of 2x which is what we
have there so I like to draw a triangle
okay like so and you can see that here's
our angle theta anything can be written
as a fraction by putting it over one so
tangent of theta equals the opposite
side over the adjacent side now if we do
the Pythagorean theorem a squared plus B
squared equals C squared and then take
the square root you can see this is
going to be the square root of 4x
squared plus 1 okay but now it says well
what's the sine of this angle so the
sine of this angle is the opposite side
over the hypotenuse so that comes out to
2 x over the square root of 4x squared
plus 1 now if you want to get rid of the
radical in the denominator you can
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by square root of 4x squared
plus 1 to rationalize it so this would
give us 4x squared plus 1 in the
denominator 2x times the square root of
4x squared plus 1 in the numerator and
you got it okay for number 30 it says
sin
by cosine squared of alpha over one
minus sine of alpha well you can think
of this as a or ax whatever the angle is
fine but basically what we're doing is
we're working with trig expressions and
trig identities to rewrite this so
there's a little bit of a technique here
that we can use and that's like this
cosine squared of alpha over 1 minus
sine of alpha and we're going to
multiply by a conjugate so instead of
minus here I'm going to put 1 plus the
sine of alpha whatever I do to the
denominator I have to do to the
numerator this is really like
multiplying what by 1 if I multiply the
denominator and the outer are gonna
cancel negative sine alpha positive sine
alpha so I just get the first and the
last and then the numerator is just
going to be what we have here which is
cosine squared alpha 1 plus sine alpha
all over 1 minus sine squared alpha but
you know your Pythagorean tree gotten a
sine squared plus cosine squared is
equal to 1 here let me write that down
sine squared plus cosine squared equals
1 so you can see if I take 1 minus sine
squared what does that equal
cosine squared so this whole quantity is
actually equal to cosine squared alpha
and you can see now that the numerator
denominator cancelling and we're just
left with 1 plus sine alpha and that's
as far as we can reduce or condense that
expression ok for number 31 it says of x
equals 2 tangent of theta right the
square root of 4 plus x squared as a
trigonometric function okay this is
interesting so now see how x equals 2
tangent of theta we can put that in
place of X right there
you know just substitute and let's see
what we get so we get 4 plus instead of
X our putting in 2 tangent of theta okay
squared and then when we square this we
get 4 tangent squared theta plus 4 and
we can factor out the 4 so this is going
to be 4 times 1 plus tangent squared
theta and remember your Pythagorean trig
identities remember how we were doing
science squared plus cosine squared
equals 1 well there's another one that's
1 plus tangent squared which is equal to
secant squared so this whole thing here
secant squared theta so now we have four
secant squared theta but what's the
square root of that well that's going to
be equal to two secant theta and you got
it
number 32 it says evaluate sine square
root of 14 degrees plus sine squared of
20 degrees plus sine squared of 76
degrees plus sine squared of 70 degrees
so how would you do that one well one
thing that you might notice is that see
how 14 degrees in 76 degrees see how
these add up to 90 degrees and same
thing with 20 and 70 see how those add
up to 90 so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna make use of Co functions and the
idea here is that instead of sine square
root of 76 I'm gonna write this as
cosine squared of 90 minus 76 so cosine
of 90 minus theta is the same as sine of
theta and then I'm just squaring that so
90 minus 76 you can see it actually is
the same as 14 degrees and just like we
were talking about here sine squared
plus cosine squared equals 1 this
Pythagorean trig identity sine squared
of 14 plus cosine square root of 14
that's gonna add up to 1 so we can group
those together and then same thing over
here sine squared of 70 this is the same
thing as cosine squared of 90 minus 70
which is 20 and we can group these ones
together sine square root of 20 plus
cosine square root of 20 is 1 so you can
see we have 1 plus 1 which is equal to 2
okay number 33 it says solve sine
squared of X plus sine of X equals 0 and
what we're gonna do for this one is
we're gonna write it as a general
solution so the first thing that I would
do here is I would factor out a sine so
we have a sine of X and then you'd be
left with sine of X plus 1 equals 0 now
if we set each of these groups each of
these factors equal to 0 and you can see
that we're gonna get sine of X equals 0
and here we're going to get sine of X
equals negative 1 if I subtract the one
on the other side so now we go to the
unit circle when we say to ourselves
well where is sine equal to 0 well sine
is 0 where the y coordinate is equal to
0 and that's going to be right here at 1
0 and over here at negative 1 0 and
we're a sign going to be negative 1 well
that's gonna be the where the y
coordinate is negative 1
and that's gonna be right here at zero
comma negative one now because they
didn't specify you know an interval like
zero to two pi for example we're gonna
write this as a general solution but
what you can do is see these ones that
are across from each other at 0 and PI
we can group those together and we can
say well it's going to be X is going to
equal to 0 plus pi times n where n is an
integer so if you start at 0 and then
you add PI and say Animus 2 then that
would be 2 pi and if n was 3 would be 3
pi you don't have to write the 0 I
probably would just write x equals pi
times n but just to show you for this
one though here we're at 3 PI over 2 but
there's not a corresponding point that's
like diametrically opposed so we're just
gonna say plus 2 pi n so this is going
to be our general solution right there
and you've got it so for number 34 this
one says solving the interval from 0 to
2 pi including 0 but not including 2 pi
so cosine squared X minus sine squared x
equals negative 1 now you remember from
earlier in this video we talked about
science cripples cosine squared equals 1
if we rewrite that Pythagorean identity
cosine squared is equal to 1 minus sine
squared of X then we'll just bring these
other quantities down let's combine like
terms 1 minus 2 sine squared x equals
negative 1 let's subtract 1 from both
sides we got negative 2 sine squared X
equals negative 2 divide both sides by
negative 2 and so we have sine squared X
equals 1 take the square root of both
sides when you do that you get two
answers plus or minus 1 and now we have
to ask ourselves where a sine positive 1
or negative 1 from 0 to 2 pi well sine
is the y-coordinate and sine is going to
be 1 here and here because this point is
0 1 and this point here is 0 negative 1
so we're just going to say PI over 2 and
3 PI over 2 is what x equals and we just
wrote it those two points not as a
general solution because they gave us
the interval so for number 35 it says
find the exact value of sine of 105
degrees using a sum or difference
formula so this section is we're talking
a lot about identities so one of the
identities you probably know
ready as a sign of angle u plus V is
equal to sine of U times cosine V +
cosine u times sine of E but if you're
subtracting like sine of U minus V and
this is going to be minus here okay so
we have to think of our to ourselves
what two angles add to 105 degrees or
subtract to 105 degrees so we're
familiar with you know the trig values
on the unit circle so the ones that jump
out to me here are that 60 and 45 right
so 60 plus 45 so we're going to use the
sum formula because we're adding so this
is equal to the sine of 60 times the
cosine of 45 plus the cosine of 60 times
the sine of 45 so on the unit circle now
sine of 60 that's going to be like right
here and we know that that value is
square root 3 over 2 the cosine of 45
that value is gonna be right there that
sort of 2 over 2 cosine of 60 that's 1/2
and sine of 45 that square root 2 over 2
so I'm just getting all these values
from the unit circle review that if you
need to and then here we're just
multiplying the numerators together the
denominators together and we have a
common denominator so we can combine
these into one fraction square root of 6
plus square root of 2 over 4 don't make
the mistake you can't combine those two
radicals you can't say square root of 8
or over 4 or anything like that because
these two quantities are different for
36 though it says right they give an
expression as the sine cosine or tangent
of an angle and they're giving us this
expression here tangent of 20 + tangent
of 30 over 1 minus tangent of 20 times
the tangent of 30 and you probably
recognize this as the tangent sum
formula so tangent of U plus V equals
tangent u plus tangent V over 1 minus
tangent u times tangent V so you might
have to go back and memorize some of
those sum and difference formulas and
some of the trig identities when you're
preparing for this exam but what they're
doing is they're giving us the right
side of the equation here we're going to
condense it to the left side we can see
that U and V are 20 and 30 so this is
just going to be tangent of 20 plus 30
or we can just condense that down to
tangent of 50 degrees and you got it
okay for 37
it says find the exact value of cosine
of U minus V given that sine of U is
negative seven twenty-fifths cosine of V
is negative 5/13 and both are in the
third quadrant and we want to find
cosine of U minus V this is the cosine
difference formula here you can add that
to your note sheet or refresh on that
one now if you were adding then you
would be subtracting here it's like the
opposite with sine it's the same like if
you're adding you're adding if you
subtract you subtract with cosine it's
the opposite if you subtract you had if
you had you subtract but let's go ahead
and draw some diagrams here so for angle
u you're right here and for angle V or
right here okay in the third quadrant
and it says the sine of U which is the
opposite over the hypotenuse and with
the cosine of V that's the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse now all we have to
do is do the Pythagorean theorem to find
the missing side since these are both
right triangles here and if you
recognize this this is actually a
Pythagorean triple this would be 24 but
because we're going to the left it's
gonna be negative 24 this is a also
Pythagorean triple this is going to be
negative 12 negative cuz you're going
down but you don't have to necessarily
memorize the Pythagorean triples it's
helpful you can always just go back to
the a squared plus B squared equals C
squared but now what we're gonna do is
we're going to expand out cosine of U
minus V using the right side of this
identity here so the cosine of U is
adjacent over hypotenuse negative
twenty-four twenty-fifths
the cosine of V is adjacent over
hypotenuse plus the sine of U which is
opposite over hypotenuse and the sine of
V which is opposite over hypotenuse and
all we have to do now is simplify that
out so let's go to the calculator on
this let's see what I can figure out
here for us so we've got negative 24
times negative five okay which is a
hundred and twenty okay and this over
here is 84 and let's see what the
denominator is we have 25 times 13 which
is 325 325 so now if we add these
together what does that come out to 204
over 325 okay number 38 it says use the
figure below to find the exact value of
the C
of to theta now notice this is just one
theta so we're trying to find a double
angle or a double this angle now seeking
of two theta remember this is the
reciprocal of cosine of two theta right
so it's like 1 over cosine of 2 theta
and cosine of 2 theta there's a number
of different versions of the double
angle formula for cosine of theta cosine
of 2 theta but we're going to use this
one here cosine squared theta minus sine
squared theta okay so this is an
identity these are equal so we're gonna
go to our triangle here we're gonna do
the Pythagorean theorem we're gonna get
square root of 17 for the hypotenuse
right so now we went from a double angle
to a single angle so what's the cosine
of theta it's adjacent over hypotenuse
but we're squaring it and then what's
the sine of theta squared well that's
going to be opposite over hypotenuse and
if we simplify we get 16 17 minus 117th
because the square and the square root
cancel that gives us 15 17 but we just
solve for the cosine of 2 theta we
really want the reciprocal because we're
trying to solve for secant of 2 theta so
this is actually going to be 1715 and
you got it so for number 39 now it says
solving the interval from zero to 2pi
sine of 2x equals cosine of X so you can
see we have another double angle here
and this is a single angle so what we're
gonna want to do is use our double angle
formula for sine so sine of 2x is the
same as 2 sine of X times cosine of X so
these are and identity their equivalent
they're identical and so now we're going
to get everything on one side of the
equation set it equal to zero and solve
so notice how in this group in this
group there's a cosine let's go ahead
and factor that cosine X out so we're
left with 2 sine X minus 1 equals 0 and
now if we set each factor equal to 0 we
get cosine of X equals 0 and choose sine
X minus 1 equals 0 add 1 to both sides
divide by 2 and you can see that sine of
X equals 1/2 and cosine of X equals 0 so
we go to our unit circle now say where
does cosine equals 0 well cosine is X
on the unit circle so it's going to be 0
here at 0 comma 1 and here at 0 comma
negative 1 and sign is going to be 1/2
at let's see so sine is the y-coordinate
so on a unit circle 1/2 is going to be
right here at PI over 6 and over here at
5 PI over 6 so if we put all together
we've got PI over 6 PI over 2 5 PI over
6 and 3 PI over 2 and so those are going
to be your solutions between 0 & 2 pi I
hope this video helped you to prepare
for your precalc is an subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos in my Morrow's math tutor and
youtube channel this channel is all
about making learning math less
stressful so that you can raise your
grade pass your class and go on to
pursue your dreams I'll see you in the
future videos